do you think there's something outside
of the capabilities of a computer that
is present in our universe you have a
disagreement with roger penrose
the nature of consciousness he he thinks
that consciousness is more than just a
computation
uh do you think all of it the whole
shebang is can be can be a competition
yeah i've had many fascinating debates
with uh sir roger penrose and obviously
he's he's famously and i read you know
emperors of new mind and and um and his
books uh his classical books uh and they
they were pretty influential and you
know in the 90s and um he believes that
there's something more you know
something quantum that is needed to
explain consciousness in the brain um i
think about what we're doing actually at
deepmind and what my career is being
we're almost like true rings champion so
we are pushing turing machines or
classical computation to the limits what
are the limits of what classical
computing can do now um and at the same
time i've also studied neuroscience to
see and that's why i did my phd in was
to see also to look at you know is there
anything quantum in the brain from a
neuroscience or biological perspective
and um and so far i think most
neuroscientists and most mainstream
biologists and neuroscientists would say
there's no evidence of any quantum uh
systems or effects in the brain as far
as we can see it's it can be mostly
explained by classical uh classical
theories so
and then so there's sort of the the
search from the biology side and then at
the same time there's the raising of the
water uh at the bar from what classical
turing machines can do uh uh and
and you know including our new ai
systems and as you alluded to earlier um
you know i think ai especially in the
last decade plus has been a continual
story now of surprising uh events uh and
surprising successors knocking over one
theory after another of what was thought
to be impossible you know from go to
protein folding and so on and so i think
um
i would be very hesitant to bet against
how far the uh universal turing machine
and classical computation paradigm can
go and and my betting would be
that all of certainly what's going on in
our brain uh can probably be mimicked or
or approximated on a classical machine
um not you know not requiring something
metaphysical or quantum and we'll get
there with some of the work with alpha
fold
which i think begins the journey of
modeling this beautiful and complex
world of biology
so you think all the magic of the human
mind comes from this
just a few pounds of mush
of a biological computational mush
that's
akin to some of the neural networks
not directly but in spirit that deep
mind has been working with well look i
think it's um you say it's a few you
know of course it's this is the i think
the biggest miracle of the universe is
that um it is just a few pounds of mush
in our skulls and yet it's also our
brains are the most complex objects in
the in that we know of in the universe
so there's something profoundly
beautiful and amazing about our brains
and
i
think that it's an incredibly uh
incredible efficient machine and and uh
uh uh and it's you know phenomenal
basically and i think that building ai
one of the reasons i want to build ai
and i've always wanted to is i think by
building an intelligent artifact like ai
and then comparing it to the human mind
um that will help us unlock the
uniqueness and the true secrets of the
mind that we've always wondered about
since the dawn of history like
consciousness dreaming uh creativity
uh or emotions what are all these things
right we've we've wondered about them
since since the dawn of humanity and i
think one of the reasons and you know i
love philosophy and philosophy of mind
is we found it difficult is there
haven't been the tools for us to really
other than introspection to from very
clever people in in history very clever
philosophers to really investigate this
scientifically but now suddenly we have
a plethora of tools firstly we have all
the neuroscience tools fmir machines
single cell recording all of this stuff
but we also have the ability computers
and ai to build uh intelligent systems
so i think that um
uh
you know i think it is amazing what the
human mind does and um and and i i'm
kind of in awe of it really and uh and i
think it's amazing that with our human
minds we're able to build things like
computers and and actually even you know
think and investigate about these
questions i think that's also a
testament to the human mind yeah the
universe built the human mind that now
is building computers that help
us understand both the universe and our
own human mind right that's exactly it i
mean i think that's one you know one
could say we we are
maybe we're the mechanism by which the
universe is going to try and understand
itself
you